thank you so much for coming it's a
great pleasure for me to welcome a good
friend a colleague and also very
distinguished very distinguished
colleague who is excelled in many
different domains dr. Harvey Fineberg I
would say back to Pittsburgh because he
grew up in Pittsburgh and he went to
Taylor Allderdice high school he left
Pittsburgh after graduating from high
school and went to Harvard where he
received all of his degrees and rose
through the ranks and for 13 years
served as the Dean of the School of
Public Health which is now called the
Chan School of Public Health at Harvard
and became Provost at Harvard and
subsequent to that position he went to
the what was then the Institute of
Medicine which is now called a National
Academy of Medicine where he served as
president for 12 years and at the
beginning of last year joined the Gordon
and Betty Moore Foundation as its
president there are a lot of things that
I could say about Harvey in the interest
of time I will not but I will say a few
things as an academic as somebody who's
an expert in medicine public health &
policy as an academic leader as leader
of one of the three major national
academies which has had huge impact on
policy issues on the national and
international level this morning at
breakfast he was telling me one of the
things we may not know publicly advising
the government on things in an unbiased
impartial way there are a lot of
activities at the National Academies do
and played a role in this when I was in
Washington even though we overlapped as
academic colleagues in neighboring
institutions for me
years I didn't have the pleasure of
knowing him but I met him in Washington
and I personally benefited from
interactions with him from his insights
experience and perspectives at the
National Science Foundation for a number
of things so I'm grateful to you Harvey
for that they're also some stories
couple of stories that i want to tell
you at least one story last year I met
Harvey at the god and more foundation I
not only have a enormous respect for
Harvey but also for enormous respect for
the institution that was founded by God
and more because Harvey represents many
of the characteristics and ideals for
which Gordon Moore has been long known
and I had the pleasure and privilege of
being the God and more scholar at
Caltech in 2004 and had the pleasure of
meeting him I met Harvey at the god and
more foundation last summer and so he
asked me where do you live I knew he was
from Pittsburgh he said Northumberland
Street he said which house and I
described the house to him the cross
street you know just near Whiteman and
Northumberland he said I was the paper
boy for that house
and then I said what do you think of the
house he said have never been inside so
Mary and my wife Mary and I are
delighted to have Harvey stay with us
during this visit so without I also want
to thank Mary for hosting a session with
Harvey and the students yesterday and
Amy and others so thank you very much we
have some students from the tailor out
of this school who are here also Karen
Feinstein from the Jewish Health Care
Foundation and we have colleagues from
Pittsburgh aunt Lavina Dean of the
Medical School from Pittsburgh another
so thank you thank you all for coming
and Harvey's title is here so with that
or we welcome
super I want to thank you so very much
for this very generous introduction but
even more i want to thank you and all
your colleagues here at CMU for an
absolutely stellar day day and a quarter
that I've had the privilege to be here
with you I learned so much listening and
talking with the students I learned even
more listening to the faculty who are
doing so many vital and exciting
projects in and around the worlds of
science machine learning information
technology health care and much much
more I know that I had a very very tiny
sampling I didn't get to see any of the
plays I didn't hear any of the music I
know that there are talents galore in
this great institution and I also know
how lucky we are and I say we I still
consider myself a Pittsburgh native to
have you subra and you marry here at
Carnegie Mellon University thank you so
much for your welcome and for making me
feel so much a part of the community
again I'm also thrilled to have the
chance to meet a few of my Allderdice
colleagues go dragons we're good thank
you for coming it I can tell just from a
few minutes talking with the students
and teacher that school is as exciting a
place as it ever was and it's a thrill
to have a chance to interact just even
briefly with the students from
Allderdice this is a lecture named in
honor of herb Simon herb Simon needs no
introduction to this institution because
herb Simon was an incredible figure and
intellect a polymath a man who knew no
bounds
in intellectual reach and in consequence
he was instrumental in the early days of
computation science and machine learning
he was critical in the establishment of
principles of behavior in the field of
economics organizational behavior he was
recognized widely for his achievements
with a Nobel Prize in Economics with the
Turing prize so he was renowned in his
day and he said something that I was
reminded of in one of our sessions
earlier today he said that a wealth of
information is associated with a poverty
of attention a wealth of information and
a poverty of attention and it's a great
backdrop for the theme that I want to
talk with you about today which is in
this world of technology and abundant
information especially for those in the
health care business how do we keep the
patient and the needs of the patient
central and foremost and constantly in
mind and I want to share with you some
thoughts about what that juxtaposition
of the information age and the needs of
patients means for medicine today and
particularly for medical education but
the story of technology in our modern
usage and its effect in relationship to
medicine has a curious beginning with a
physician named Jacob Bigelow as any of
you heard of this gentleman jakob
Bigelow no reason you would have he was
born in sudbury massachusetts in 1787 an
18th century birth
he was a very great student of nature in
fact he became a renowned botanist at a
very early age he published a collection
of plants and depictions of those
drawings that he did himself he
published initially three volumes on
botany in America these were the native
medicinal plants of the United States in
producing this work which was actually
the first published colored document in
the united states that was not hand
colored as a printed document he
invented the process of aqua tinting so
that the printing could be done he then
became one of five editors of the first
pharmacopoeia of the united states he
earned his medical degree at that other
school in pennsylvania you know about on
the east which was the first medical
school in the United States at the
University of Pennsylvania he then came
back and was practicing medicine in
association with a very renowned surgeon
named James Jackson he went on to design
and build and construct the first garden
cemetery in the United States the Mount
Auburn cemetery which he conceived of in
1825 and built in 1830 before that
people were buried in graveyards usually
near or sometimes even under churches
and he decided as a physician and a
student of disease that this was not a
healthy environment none of that is the
reason I'm telling you about him though
he was quite impressive for that in
the year 18 eighteen he was appointed
the rumsford professor at Harvard and in
that capacity his mandate was to teach
about the applied arts and in that 1820s
he delivered a series of lectures which
he by the way built all of the models
and all of the demonstrations himself to
show all about the applied arts to any
number of practical needs in everyday
life and at the end of the 1820s he
published a 534 page volume which he
entitled the elements of technology
taken chiefly from a course of lectures
delivered at Cambridge on the
application of the sciences to the
useful arts now published for the use of
seminaries and students he was the one
who popularized the term technology and
it was he who subsequently was quite
instrumental in helping to found in the
early days what became the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology and he went on
in medicine to do one other very
important thing he wrote a discourse
which he entitled a discourse on
self-limited disease and what he
contributed in that discourse which
appeared in the middle 1830s was a
counter action and an antidote to what
had been the era of heroic medical
intervention the era of bleeding and
purging not things we think of today as
being very very successful but it was
Bigelow who was among the founders of
the recognition that medicine could
sometimes do most by doing least and in
fact many historians of Madison believe
that it wasn't
till well into the 20th century when the
typical patient encountering the typical
physician on average came out the better
because of the encounter so this was a
time when sometimes doing less was
actually doing more by the end of the
19th century medical education in the
United States was essentially completely
based on an apprenticeship model you
would learn by watching and doing there
were more than a hundred and fifty
medical schools so-called in the United
States at the turn of the century and it
wasn't until the famous report and
assessment by Abraham Flexner in 1910
commissioned by another Carnegie
Institution the Carnegie Foundation that
Flexner reported that medical education
was misguided misdirected foul and
useless and he recommended closing all
but 31 of the schools in united states
and canada he had visited every one of
the 155 and he had in mind a model which
he said would do better at preparing
physicians for the modern world of the
early 20th century and that was a model
based on science a model derived from
Johns Hopkins at the time a major
university committed to training in
medicine derived from the European
mostly German model of science based
training and after the Flexner report
scores of medical schools closed or
merged he recommended that all be based
at university
this is where university-based hospitals
also began to take shape and where the
fundamental training of medical students
was grounded in a series of the basic
sciences to be mastered prior to
clinical exposure and clinical learning
this became the standard for medical
education that continued to set the tone
and still influences very powerfully
medical education a century later but
there have been a series of equally
important reforms and repositioning of
medical education over the decades these
have been aimed either at changing the
goal of medical education that is if you
think of it the product what is the
doctor to do over time how does that
change or it focused on changing the
content that you needed to instill or
convey either as knowledge or skills in
order for the doctor to fulfill whatever
role you had decided was the right role
or the reform focused on the method of
learning how do you teach how do you
learn and what is the best way to master
the necessary content to fulfill the
desired role and one story of the
transformations in medical education
over the 20th and now into the 21st
century is a series of major
perturbations and adjustments grounded
still in science but in rethinking what
is the role of the doctor what content
does the doctor need to master and what
is the best means to enable the doctor
in training to get that mastery so for
in the 1950s first at Case Western
Reserve which by the way was one of the
half dozen or so schools that Flexner
cited as being at the high quality are
you have to tell me when was pit found
it i as a medical school do you know
1867 so it was part of the Reformation
in that period as well and I'll have to
learn more exactly what pit did in that
century ago but in the earliest days I'm
sure that it was a very different
looking institution than it became after
Flexner so in the in the 1950s Case
Western Reserve introduced a model of
learning about the sciences that was
grounded on organ systems rather than
basic sciences alone so instead of
learning only anatomy and chemistry and
histology and pathology instead students
began to study the digestive system the
nervous system all of the body systems
and to interpret the science all under
the guise of understanding the
physiology of that organ system that
represented a major sea change in the
way doctors were beginning to be trained
in the 1950s and then subsequently one
of the next big changes was in the form
of learning the method of learning which
was problem-based learning this was
introduced in a number of places but
particularly at McMaster University in
Canada and spread to many other
institutions and here the idea was you
don't just learn the basic science you
don't just learn about an organ system
your best way to really learn and absorb
what you need to know in order to care
for patients is to study cases and to
learn from those cases the science
and the relevant pathology and the
reticle relevant course of disease so
case based instruction became a very
important part but what really then
began to multiply is the number of
different roles that doctors were
expected and that schools were trying to
prepare doctors to fulfill so today you
have doctors who are studying medicine
and business medicine and public policy
medicine and each of the sciences and
you have a proliferation of opportunity
on the one side for clinical roles and
on the other side you have a
proliferation of a mandate to schools
preparing these students to provide
different tracks of opportunity for them
to prepare in those ways what is
critical to me is that in these
proliferation of skills and
opportunities for doctors that we never
lose sight of the centrality of the
patient and the clinical
responsibilities of the doctor who will
be the caregiver what does that require
well if you think about a problem which
has become very well appreciated in
medicine today which is the problem of
patient safety and the responsibility of
the system of care to ensure the safety
of the patient the Institute of Medicine
when it did a landmark study on errors
in medicine estimated that tens of
thousands of people every year lost
their lives because of errors in the
delivery of care it was if you ranked it
according to causes of mortality in the
top 10 in the United States how do we
understand that as a problem from an
educators point of view how do you deal
with preparing doctors to practice safe
medicine well there are many different
possible points of view one point of
view says well the reason that we have
errors in medicine is that we have
sloppy care and the reason we have
sloppy cares that we allow into practice
in nursing in medicine and direct
contact with patients individuals who do
not care enough about taking good care
of the patient and so if you adopt this
reasoning of the problem your solution
is to do a better job in selecting the
right people to go into these
professions the caring professions in
the first place so if you take the
ethicist point of view that the problem
is you just don't care enough you say
well the answer is find people who do
before you let them harm any patient now
another approach is to say well it's not
that there is people who don't care it's
that we haven't done a good enough job
in educating them about what they need
to do to practice safe medicine so if
you want people to be able to practice
safe medicine it's not because they
don't care it's because they haven't
been trained to know exactly what the
correct protocol is exactly what is the
right procedure exactly what should be
the sequence of testing and how do you
ensure that the right medication is the
one that you order so if you think that
the solution is education you want to
get to the doctors in school and in
residency and beyond and make sure that
they are trained properly as you won't
want nurses to be trained properly but
if you say well
eight it's not just I don't care it's
not just we're not training them but
look where we practice and look how we
practice we have kept residence on duty
for scores of hours at a time 36 and we
have kept doctors under stress in the
emergency rooms and we have nurses that
are overly burdened with their work and
that psychologically under stress over
worked with extreme pressure people will
make mistakes and so if you say that the
problem well it's not ethical problem
it's not an educational problem it's a
psychological problem of overwhelming
stress pressure and circumstances of
work then the solution is well you cut
down on residency hours you staff
adequately the nursing that's required
so that you have a reduction of the
stress on your nurses you provide the
kind of backup and training that will
allow people to practice more sanely and
therefore it will be safer so if you
believe the problem is the circumstance
of care and the psychological burden you
approach the problem that way well you
might say no it's not quite that really
the problem is that we incentivize
doctors and others to be sloppy because
we don't pay them only for doing the
right things we pay them for doing more
things so if you believe that the
problem is that the incentives are wrong
and the pay is misplaced and the rewards
don't go along with safe care just goes
along with more care then you'd say well
the answer is we have to change the way
that we reinforce payment to doctors
well all of these I think have a point
but i'm here at carnegie mellon to tell
you that
fundamentally none of those and even all
of those get to the heart of what is the
problem the heart of the problem is
actually an engineering problem it's
about the whole of the system it's about
the processes of care it's about having
a medical care delivery capacity which
not only is capable of delivering safe
care but is virtually incapable of
delivering unsafe care now if we are
going to take doctors today and we're
going to prepare them for the right kind
of practice to the patient we have to
have a system of care that enables them
to practice safe high quality and good
value care but that will not be enough
and it will not be enough going forward
because of the extreme and amazing
amount of information which is now
coming available to the clinician in
order to care for the patient right now
we are making very partial use of the
available information I heard about a
number of individuals here at this
university who are working hard to make
better use of the available information
that we know today but what we have
today is nothing compared to what is
coming there are three great streams of
information flow that are relevant to
our health that are going to be coming
in abundance the first is all of the
clinical information about us everything
from our history through our
examinations and all of our testing and
the ability over time to do different
kinds of testing with different kinds of
information is going to open up
whole new ways of thinking about
tracking risk for patients over time
right now if you go to your doctor and
they measure a certain metabolites in
your blood and you ask is it normal or
is it not normal the answer to that
question depends today on where your
value sits compared to a cross section
of the public not known to be suffering
from any ailment well in the future if
you can have multiple sequential tests
very cheaply done monitored even in some
cases continually then your reference
point is not going to be the population
it will be you and your own history and
where you are tending now to be at risk
so clinical information is going to be
dramatically transformed secondly
everyone is aware of genomic information
which is compiled with metabolomic
information which is further being
amplified in populations around the
world this is going to be and is already
an incredibly challenging problem which
I'm happy to say I saw here also a
number of people hard at work at parsing
and making interpretable and speeding
the capacity to interpret this level of
detailed information but the third great
stream is going to be all of the
information about you and your
environment that you experience directly
and indirectly and how that impinges on
your life chances and on your
opportunities we are going to need
doctors of the future who are
effectively informit itions as well as
being pediatricians or obstetricians or
any other specialty we will need to have
capacities to interpret data and apply
it to the benefit of the patient and
this brings
me too a final point that I want to make
about the relationship to the patient
and the application of this technology
it is sometimes argued that the ideal
model today is partnership between
patients and clinicians to make joint
decisions and I believe that that is a
very very good model but i would add
it's not the ideal model for every
individual or in every circumstance
there are times when individuals need a
doctor who will just tell them what to
do there are times when people need a
clinician who will just support them in
their own decision-making over time and
what I believe we really need in the
training of doctors in this new age of
information and the new relationship to
patients are clinicians who have the
capacity to not exert their style of
thinking and decision-making on a
patient but rather to adapt to the needs
of that patient to deliver the kind and
quality of care that that patient needs
at that time and that means placing a
very high premium on the human
interaction and the ability of the
clinician to remain the close healer and
the caregiver to every patient so the
challenges and opportunities for
medicine have never been greater and
it's going to take not only doctors but
a complete system of educators of care
systems of intellectual endeavor of
science and of the kind of research that
we saw in abundance in the course of
this last day that will create the
conditions when patients can receive
the quality of care that they deserve
and that we want to make sure is given
to every single individual thank you
very much dr. Feinberg thank you very
much for your thoughtful remarks it's
really a pleasure to have you here we
have a few minutes for a Q&A session I
want to invite the audience to
participate in this session and our
microphones that are going around and
that if you raise your hand a microphone
will come your way thank you so much for
that inspiring lecture I guess my
question relates to two themes I heard
in your comments one about the
information overload and the other about
the evolution of medical education to
meet the needs of the patient so if we
think about the caregiver who's meeting
all these demands and the constraints
that exist in the formal educational
component of that person's training what
do you think we can do during training
to support medical professionals in
being lifelong learners and how do you
see that fitting in with the issues you
raised oh thank you mark I think this is
a really critical point because the
concept of medical education is not
about medical school and it's not about
just pre-med and medical school it's not
even about high school and then college
and then medical school it's about a
lifelong commitment to learning because
in fact what we used to tell our medical
students is that we know half of what
we're teaching them is wrong we just
don't know which half
and they will discover which half in the
course of the ensuing decades and i can
give you many many examples of truths i
was taught that subsequently we no
longer hold as so truth so your point i
think is especially important in
instilling the idea that medicine is
actually a lifelong process if you are
in the caregiving relationship a
lifelong process of learning and
caregiving and it's an iterative process
and i think that if you enter the
profession without that clarity of
understanding you're destined either to
be frustrated or to be a progressively
less qualified practitioner right
question there may I suggest that you
introduce yourself without a prior to
the question hello my name is Dave
Stewart and I'm from Nova Scotia and the
the government there has taken a radical
new direction of basically be coming out
there getting out of the healthcare
business their Department of Health is
actually getting more into the policy
side and actually taking the health care
and giving it to the health authorities
and their role they anticipate is to be
looking forward with the data that
you're talking about to actually be able
to forecast with the needs of the
population would be are there other
jurisdictions in North America they're
starting to look at this in the whole
issue of deep data and the fact that
I've got to Fitbit on I got personal
information up the wazoo oh there it's a
it's a great question first you know I
you know the definition of a Canadian
don't know it's a Canadian as is
basically an unarmed American with
health insurance
so you know we and we envy you a couple
of points this you know whether the role
goes to government or agencies of
government or too large insurers or two
systems of caregivers who are going to
be than the locus of this kind of
population plus individual analysis I
think remains a fluid question right now
in different places and different
histories and different jurisdictions
different concerns about issues of
privacy for example in addition to the
analysis I think what's going on now in
experimentation and as you know every
province is also not doing it exactly
the same way so experimentation with in
Canada and frankly within the different
states of the u.s. is very I think very
promising in terms of revealing these
types of questions what I believe is is
holding up progress isn't so much a will
but it's a combination right now of the
analytic technology that's genuinely
applicable and adequate protections to
assure the absence of misuse of the
information personally on the latter
point my feeling is that i would i'd
love to be able to protect access to
private personal information but hey
i've used a charge card at the checkout
i bought some things online i know that
there's a dossier of everything about me
somewhere out there and it's for sale
because it's a value to somebody heaven
knows why but they're willing to pay for
it and they're willing to pay for every
one of you every one of your information
it's out there so i personally believe
that i would put more emphasis on
penalizing misuse than on trying to
continually only protect against
exposure i think if we had really severe
penalties for misuse I'd feel a little
more comfortable because I feel it's
already out there
yes oh I'm sorry just blaze's a because
but this was one of my altered I
students so you're in charge God hi I'm
a junior at alder days um I've really
been interested in medical studies for a
long time and I've always thought about
being a doctor and its really been
interesting um I was wondering what's
your opinion on the prevalence of
robotic surgery and different types of
laparoscopic surgery and medicine it's
there so that you know one of the
features of Technology if you look at
technology in general in medicine over
time is that it has sometimes
progressively distanced the doctor from
the patient so for example a Stanley
riser in 1970s wrote a book called
medicine and the reign of Technology
already it was considered technology
back then and he cited for example the
development of the stethoscope which
enabled the doctor no longer to lay her
or his ear right on the chest of the
patient so you were distancing and
nowadays art can tell me but I think the
students are all using ultrasound which
is you know yet another remove from the
patient and so fundamentally technology
of this kind has that risk of the
progressive distancing on the other hand
where you have technologies like
laparoscopy and robotic surgery
laparoscopy has radically reduced the
trauma of surgery in many instances
because you can do surgery with a much
smaller intrusion to access the actual
problem in the body and with robotic
surgery the appeal of it is that it is
much more precise in its movement and
controllable compared to the human hand
all of these technologies
in order to be proved need not simply to
be better in principle but to be tested
and proved out in practice and that's
where sometimes we get surprised because
we thought it was going to be better but
actually patients do just as well with
the other or sometimes even better so it
requires testing but the trends of of
laparoscopy and robotics are probably
here to stay okay art I would offer to
comments and the question would be what
do you think of my comments okay I'll be
prepared so as we shift from volume to
value as you've described this and led
by Medicare although it's very inchoate
and halting to change the incentives
that will ensure that we do indeed ship
from volume to value the question the
comment would be value is evidence-based
as you pointed out medicine can only
operate if it exploits and advantages
itself by using the best science that we
have at a point in time now there are
two ways of accomplishing that one is to
teach people science the other is to
teach our physicians to be scientists so
to give you one example in our school
all of our students are mandated to do
research from the day they enter medical
school this is the only medical school
in the country in fact that has debt as
a requirement for graduation there are
schools that do it in five years they
have to pay an extra year of tuition
there are students there are schools
that do it on a volunteer basis but for
us it's a mandate and the reason it's a
mandate is because what a student
discovers that he or she has the
intellectual reach and the
the potential to apply their own
creativity to the solution of a
scientific problem two things can happen
where physicians can become scientists
but even if they don't they become
better physicians because they learn an
analytic rigor if I were very ill and
had a complex of symptoms and signs that
then correspond to see cylinder bore
Harrison I don't want to be the hands of
a physician we had that kind of
imaginative potential and creativity so
I offer this is a comment to point out
that using our school as an example and
because you talked a little bit about
the people that go to medical school in
the first place beside their
narcissistic heroism another dimension
another dimension is creativity so our
school for example admit students who
are poets choreographers entrepreneurs
composers because that kind of
creativity is often generalizable to the
product that we hope to develop that's
comment number one common should we let
Harvey response our comment number two
never has to do with how it is that we
learn in the first place and you know
the great fault of K through 12
education is that it's stereotypic we
teach all the people all the kids the
same way but we teach all medical
students the same way and yet that's not
how our brains are structured our brains
are different one from the other some of
the saloon best early in the morning
some late at night some by laptop some
by lecture some by Brooks some by
mentor-mentee relationship some black
problem-based learning but that isn't
the way we teach that's not the way
we're structured I can tell you but
please don't tell my students this I
don't care if they ever go to a lecture
all i care about is what they learn and
what they've mastered and what kind of
physician they become if they can do
that by reading a book or by a mentor
the intimacy of a mentor-mentee
relationship then I will choose that
over
the fact that they have mandatory
attendance at a lecture those are my two
comments my question is what do you
think okay i just want to remind art
that we're videotaping distant this will
be on youtube in a few minutes so the
students will all find out well whether
gods cats out of the bag for the student
no that's okay so on the on the first
question first i think it is a wonderful
thing in general for schools to be
prepared to launch in their own desired
way experiments of education and whether
it's considered as a requirement or as
an option or a style of learning or
whatever that schools special feature is
i think that's a wonderful thing
secondly i personally love the idea
especially if you're admitting poets
that you allow them to learn something
about science in the early part of their
education the one qualification i would
add is if the deeper purpose is to
ensure creative problem-solving capacity
on the part of the clinician i
personally believe that while scientific
experimentation is one avenue to instill
that there are many others many other
kinds of experiences and i would submit
for one that experience in the
information sciences and decision making
is another avenue to instill the
discipline of rigor and of creativity
which is what i think is at the root of
the experiment or of the policy to have
every student experience science so i
think that for the deeper channel that's
where that's where i would what would
would favor now on on the questions
about that where students are going to
be attracted and how we how we instill
value in and thinking about what they
are what they are doing there i think
that is
part of the responsibility of of the
medical school but your point that it
really begins more fundamentally with
education as a lifelong a proposition
and it begins in the way we educate
children as well as the way we educate
adults I think is absolutely a right
approach and I would submit what I've
seen actually at CMU over the last day
and a half of the interest and
commitment to educational excellence in
the way in which it is teaching in
addition to what it is teaching and in
the initiatives that are here as I
comment and I said you don't have a
school of education the entire
university is a school of education and
so I think that what you're describing
is critically important at every level
of learning and frankly if you've told
your students not to let their lectures
interfere with their education I'd back
you up a hundred percent the question
right here let's wait for the microphone
because we're taping this please
introduce yourself yeah it's dr.
Marshall levittown I'm the chief medical
officer at nathan adelson hospice and
I'm a hospice and palliative medicine
physician very into patient centered
care obviously and a big fan of medical
education i had the privilege of serving
on one of your committees that when
children died committee in 2003 so I
appreciate all the initiatives that you
and created through the IOM for
patient-centered care my question is
about what techniques do you think are
effective in encouraging a
patient-centered approach among medical
students residents and fellows and I
just want to offer one little insight
which is words mean a lot and when I
teach I teach about the patient's chief
concern as opposed to their chief
complaint I talk about the woman as
opposed to the female and the leg
instead of the left lower extremity so I
think some of the words that we use are
very distancing and they
don't achieve anything other than a
distance so but any thoughts you have
about medical education techniques that
are more patient-centered well thank you
so much for for the comment I first
would say that the hospice movement has
actually been in the vanguard of
providing patient centered care and I
believe that if you take the lesson from
what we've learned in hospice care which
I would say the way I describe it is
it's about the patient's goals not about
the patients problems so as you put it
it's your chief concern not your chief
complaint what do you want to experience
how important is it that you're able to
go to your granddaughters wedding etc
knowing what the goals are is really the
starting point for this and then I do
think there are ways to teach and
reinforce compassion which is really at
the heart of what we are describing yes
it helps to have people predisposed but
compassion can be taught through both
self-reflection and explicit learning
and third I think there are a series of
techniques some of which you described
in terms of the language you choose but
one of the ones that I particularly like
in the end of the clinical encounter is
for the clinician to ask the patient
tell me back what I have told you so yes
so how do you tell them
that's a great way to say it see that's
why we have great doctors all right
thank you good job I gosselin but here's
the key the key idea of this is that the
doctor is not aware of what the patient
is actually absorbed and if you don't
somehow induce the discussion to where
the patient expresses in her or his own
words for some purpose you will have
missed out on the opportunity to truly
be caring for that patient so that's
another wonderful in and I learned
something thank you wonderful Steve you
had your hand up Derek there you go
microphone is coming your way Steve
Feinberg not spelt the same way Harvey
as you know I've been on the first half
of your lecture title for decades and
collaborating with you so looking at
this from the side of technology and
statistics and data analysis as I've
aged I'd become more aware of the second
impact side from the patient's
perspective and I've come to realize how
fractured medical knowledge and
specialization is I have more ists then
I have papers published and they can
barely talk to one another let alone to
me as a patient I'm able because of my
training to actually schedule and to
organize and coordinate among them but
if you walk outside of this room and go
down the street the common man
enter woman doesn't have that capacity
so how do we take the technology and all
the information that's flowing and learn
how to allow the patients to actually
ask the right questions and to get the
right care through the kind of
educational system that we now have
that's a very profound question by the
way I consider Steve my cousin even if
he spells his name differently and I do
I certainly intellectual cousins and
what you're what you're raising is a
really profound challenge for medical
practice and there I I would say there
are several parts to it for one there's
a gap between what any one clinician
knows and what is known somewhere so
that gap when you go to one east and
that is has some other information than
the second it is not to your advantage
that there is no one who has been able
and easily to combine and compile that
so one need that we have is for easier
mechanisms for the interested and
capable clinician to have access to the
degree of knowledge currently extent
sometimes that knowledge however in all
candor does not exist in any literature
it's in the expertise and experience of
the individuals so in some cases there's
no alternative but the sequential or
combined consultation in order to take
fullest advantage but secondly I would
say that we don't do a very good job
today even for the knowledgeable and
expert patient to gain access to
relevant information that is somehow not
certified but at least identified as
reliable
so that you as a patient can gain
information directly relevant to your
experience based on the enormous
quantity of other experiences that there
have already been and if we had ways to
automatically be able to filter and
collect and codify and make available to
any one patient that would go a long way
toward helping make sense of that next
encounter with the expert clinician but
we're we're at a distance from both of
those features and what you're
describing is a really fundamental
challenge in moving from the top line to
the bottom line of this talk know how
time flies this has been a fabulous
conversation thank you so much for
spending a ladder two and a half days
with us I know that your visit is going
to spark conversations across our campus
for months to come wonderful again thank
you for being so generous with your time
we have a reception in your honor
outside I'm going to invite all of you
to join us again on behalf of dr. Suresh
and my colleagues here thank you again